Hi Steve Kaufmann here today, and
I want to talk about why you do not
need to be perfect in any foreign
language that you're learning.
Uh, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, uh, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
So why do I want to talk about perfection?
First of all, I am a dilettante learner.
I also recognize that there are people
who need the language for professional
reasons because they want to get into a
school so that they're not just dabbling
in the language, exploring, having fun
like I like to do, they actually need it.
So how good do they need
to be in the language?
First of all, there is an expression
many of you have heard and an expression
that exists in many languages uh, the
perfect can be the enemy of the good.
So if you try to be perfect, you
may end up not being very good.
Uh, if you are too obsessed with being
perfect, you might not communicate
as well as someone else who is simply
trying to communicate without worrying
about being perfect, because...
you know, speaking a foreign language
is not like being in the diving
competition at the Olympic Games.
Uh, it's not like designing a
rocket that's going to go to
the moon or building a bridge.
Uh, there, we have to be perfect.
Even if you're building a simple
structure, you've got to have 90 degree
angles, things have to be straight.
There's no room for sloppiness.
However, in communicating in the language,
there's lots of room for sloppiness.
Uh, you can still communicate.
You can still understand.
So how good do we need to be?
First of all, in my experience, as
a person who has worked with people
from many different countries where
sometimes we speak English and sometimes
we speak the other person's native
language, rarely, rarely have I dealt
with people who spoke English perfectly.
It didn't matter whether
they were Swedish, German,
French, Spanish, Japanese.
If they were speaking English,
there was always something
there with which suggested that
they weren't native speakers.
Uh, similarly, when I speak
those languages, they know
that I'm not a native speaker.
However, we aren comfortable
communicating with each other.
I do think that, uh, the standard
required for written communication
is usually higher than the standard
required for oral communication.
Uh, use of words, uh,
some aspects of grammar.
I think we're more willing to forgive
in spoken, uh, you know, conversations
than we are if you get a formal letter,
you know, an extreme example would
be some legal letter or whatever,
but even a contract, uh, there, I
think we have to be a little more
careful and the fact that we sort of
give up on the idea of being perfect.
In other words, speaking with no
accent, making no mistakes, we recognize
that we're not going to achieve
that, but that doesn't prevent us
from wanting to continue to improve.
So the question is, you know,
how do we continue to improve?
So, uh, and bear in mind that people
who have, you know, I think of Henry
Kissinger who we, you know, you can
still hear his German accent after,
gosh, I don't know how many years
of working at the highest level of
diplomacy in the English language.
So once we recognize that there are limits
to how good we can become, I think the
question then is how do we become better?
Because we would all like to be better.
We would all like to continue to improve.
And there, I think the, the, uh,
the issue is we have to be so
comfortable, so natural in the
language that without thinking about
it, we start to speak more correctly.
We start to use words and very
often it's more a matter of use
of words then nitty points, nitty
biddy, nitpicking points of grammar.
And I mean, you won't be surprised
to hear me say that that just
requires an awful lot of reading and
listening and particularly reading.
If we want to write well, let's say we
have a job for a company that's uh...
deals in English and we're writing a,
you know, commercial correspondence
you have to read a lot of that kind of
material, so that you end up gradually,
naturally using words and using phrases
and structures and terminology, the way
very proficient users of that language do.
Uh, I think it can help at LingQ to
save key phrases that are very natural,
very powerful that other people have
used so that we're imitating these very
good models of how to use the language.
And I think if we want to get closer to,
if not perfection, a very high standard
in the language, I think it's important to
focus on our ability to write the language
accurately, to use words accurately.
And when you are writing, you have time
to think about what you want to say.
You have time to look words up, you
have time to look even grammar rules up
and gradually develop, you know, habits
that will carry over into your speaking.
And so the sort of emphasis should
be on, you know, use of the language,
not necessarily on how you pronounce.
There's nothing wrong with wanting
to work on improving or making the
pronunciation more native-like,
but it's not as important.
And I think we've all had the
experience of dealing with foreigners,
you know, as an English speaker,
foreigners who use English very,
very well, but have an accent.
And we're almost more impressed with
those people because they have an
accent yet they use our language so
elegantly, so accurately, so powerfully.
And if we're able to do that
in a foreign language, even
with an accent, that's fine.
I wanted to talk about people who
have a need to perform in the language
and what is a realistic expectation.
And I don't think that
perfection is a realistic expert.
But constant improvement, the
willingness to constantly improve and
the desire to constantly engage with
the language, those are the things
that, that will keep us moving forward.
I look forward  to hearing rom you.